we're definitely doing it bad we're
doing it doing it live we're doing it
live yes it so for all of you that
usually follow games while we usually
stream at 11:00
I mean we're waiting all day for
something hot to drop and it turns out
it did bet it drops right right here in
front of all of us there's new modes
then you match stuff in overwatch who
would have thought at Chateau Gillard
Gilad Gilad an ancestral home for the
Gilad family in they have new tenants
which I assume are us as we're going to
be shooting each other and both we're
all in team deathmatch formats yeah so a
new mode this is on PTR for those that
have it on PC unfortunately as yaw roll
you are all you are all aware I can say
that word I was like it was like a mix
of y'all and you you are as you guys
know PTR is only on PC so those that are
gonna ask me is it on ps4 or Xbox one no
I don't think you're gonna get it to
chance to play it but you get the chance
to watch it so which is cool here we got
us because I've I've always kind of
wondered what deathmatch would be like
an overwatch
I'm curious and apprehensive but excited
at the same time they're not even giving
us a chance to choose alright what are
we gonna do first Ben I feel like maybe
we should open up with free-for-all
since it's the bigger button alright
bigger button that way also I I'm really
curious how this is gonna play out I
think it'll be fine I mean I'm kind of
shocked that there wasn't a team
deathmatch
yeah and with because it seems like the
the simpler way to go however the way
that this game has been based around
which is a very team centric game yeah
it was it made more sense I guess to
have objective based stuff because then
like your supports are equally as
important your tanks your rolls etc
whereas here
do you play he's gonna say uh-oh so as I
was reading a little bit about it too
apparently if you play mercy at least in
team deathmatch she actually takes kills
away from the other team or she she
moves the scores away if she also like
if if they don't seal those kills away
by making sure mercy doesn't revive any
she can still play kind of an important
role in like that's like towards like
the point system that ends the game okay
it makes sense uh so I will be
monitoring YouTube chat twitch chat as
well as GameSpot there's some people
down with some shoutouts so what's up
Christopher Fernandes hello hello and
yeah so these new modes are playable on
PC PTR if you have PC PTR also
apparently it's hard to find a game
right now we may have just gotten in
here before everyone else because we
were literally on top of this the second
it happens well what it is to is
probably people watch the developer
update and we're like oh [ __ ] I need to
go it's out on pc r whereas we kind of
knew we just couldn't say anything till
now so now we're here goob I was only
not here Tuesday because I was sick and
I'm still like I'm like 85 out of 100
yeah he's he's sitting here he's got
cough drops on the table like he's he's
ready to take care of himself
it's okay for you I came here for you
that is correct and the other thing too
that you mentioned I mean just so that
the viewers know is that the PTR like
your PTR profile is like an older one
yeah compared to like as soon as I got
it and I'm like I didn't have any of my
summer event stuff my level is much
lower than what it is on the actual live
thing which is 56 but yeah yeah I'm
higher than that yeah but yeah so we're
sitting here weighing I might actually
restart the search cuz maybe more people
no no no no no no no I don't feel like
it okay you definitely don't want to do
that in queue and I don't know do you do
you have you know I'll just take care
advice just do it you okay I think I
feel like it's it's at the moment works
like no one was here before people will
be here now okay let's give it a go it's
fine we're good we're good it's all good
yeah hi Simon what's up Daniel Velasquez
what's up Maddox low let's see way too
fast for you gaming aureole planets back
what's up shoutouts to sy axe and TK 2
cash oh you're right I was wrong he'll
look at me wrong or we're going to the
chateau as well this is the only
deathmatch gameplay on YouTube let's go
let's do it the only deathmatch gameplay
I'm gonna have to pick my boy rise how
we go what's up just
to do it a free-for-all against everyone
yo my boy your boy my boy it's your boy
look at him he's ready to go
that I'm interested to see how this goes
same I'm very very curious I thought
they'd like limit classes what this is
not a good spawn one get out of here
with this give them that oh yeah
or you know what that's fine we'll do
the trade for our first kill I was gonna
say at least with Reinhardt you probably
get those sick trade yeah yeah so you
know I I caught it I half-expected the
thing not to actually give out but
that's an interesting how do you have a
three that's a good question oh you just
got hacked you don't get anything she's
out playing you she's just too quick
she's dancing I don't we got healthier
right there yeah you need it have a
little dance again Oh even that good
uppercut we can't see the gameplay what
do you mean it's on it's on the screen
for you right would be there it's all
the same I see it I see it here and I
see it there everyone's doom fists
elemental flame gaming that feeling when
your hard drive is almost full and you
can't download the PTR we actually
almost had the same scare just now yeah
cuz it was like reallocating space and
we couldn't tell if it was like oh my
god l OS you when you still did it get
out of here
it's alright close corridors you got
fight Oh get smack just just hold down
the home that's how you're running out
you just hold down the button oh I
thought doesn't mine
doom fist get out of here dude I don't
want anything you're gonna go for that
hot trade again no I should though
there's a trap there oh my goodness from
downtown town Oh Oh car get out of here
oh my goodness stuff this is too much
Reinhardt's trash 1v1 get out of here
trick can't you see there you just you
got three tribal evolving the meta right
now all right you think reinhardt's
trash in this one v1 v1 v1 world I'm
gonna prove you wrong some people are
saying it's trash
he just got three kills I mean we're on
real tournament now okay so I remembered
yep daddy kept saying that they were
gonna have rebirth don't jump pads and
to my knowledge is this the first time
it's that like we've seen it I think so
yeah because like I thought it was gonna
be on the new maps and then they never
showed up and I was like oh right he
said jump pads a long time ago yeah I
guess this is this is where they're put
no where they're putting it in that
makes sense yeah I hear flippin doom
fists
I'm not even not even worried not even
get slapped I'm always a little worried
that's the sambar comes from the cord on
the back oh he got the other kill too
that doesn't make sense damage that's
that's not even that's not even I don't
even know is there a way to like check
score is there like if you hit tab oh
yeah that's you know middle middle snob
bad or no oh my goodness get out of here
Oh get out of here with me jumped right
on him all right here we go that's right
I did say daddy yeah oh
no I'll take that nip them I don't know
how that worked but we're not gonna
question it we're gonna keep going oh
that's pretty good actually the somber
hack seems like oh yeah okay Norma's
hacks says there were jump pads in Lucy
oh okay so alright I was mistaken but I
meant in like more of like a shooty
shooty yeah sure you're not you're not
killing people and Lucille Lucille Ball
homeboy show a lot of grunting oh
there's this you don't pat on away sis
that said no no oh no sir you know it is
you know I'm down just too wasted on a
reaper that's he's repeat deeps he's got
to go he's got to go I said have you
guys ever played Oasis okay
there you go my bad
clearly I haven't played Oasis that's
you know sometimes you can press space
to skip the respawn sequence
I just noticed this thank you yeah you
telling me thank you Sparky wolf tail
I'm woof okay
you so lucky Sombra it's gone way away
can you swap in this game mode I would
assume so because I didn't see it I'm a
courier earlier yeah but who knows we
can try later yeah I'll give it a go
here there's probably definitely a
better character to pick than Reinhard
for this but I felt like I did what
about the meta I do we're evolving the
meta to uh your own meta my meta is
flawless okay fire strikes and hammer
strikes all day this is where I am
okay got it a person on YouTube this is
the chateaux map it's new it's only on
PTR just came out today you can try it
out there's free-for-all as well as oh
god he's going for the slam dunk you got
the taken Oh or we can just clash that's
cool too and then there's also Team
Deathmatch in its basic get out of there
get him out of here
you press space you get out of there I
need I need to breathe a little now
you're dying right like so I was
thinking okay makes sense it's like very
Call of Duty mode right like the whole
point of it is to kind of get back into
the fray get into the action like right
away here is there so there's no need to
wait yeah you the faster you get back in
the faster you can die and or kill yes
20 I guess so so first game as a
character that I knew in my heart was
great
whoa sama online we we already mentioned
why he's level 56 it takes a snapshot of
yeah this isn't my actual oil profile
which is kind of sad so I wanted to play
as my new Beachbody McCree and I can't
even do it on here that's kind of cool
yeah I like all this this UI layer
alright so you know maybe Reinhardt's
not necessarily the best but he's at
least a middle
I feel like doofus might be a very high
you think the character at this point or
maybe he's just easy to get in uh maybe
I'll try I feel like Reaper is also a
pretty good one for this map because
it's all kind of tightened corridors
yeah but we'll find out we'll give it a
go
mmm whoa micro Pro PTR is the public
test realm if you go to your Blizzard
app and you click the regions there's
like Asia America and Europe on top of
that there's public test realm so if you
install public test realm you can
download it I think it's about I think
it's about ten gigs when I downloaded it
and then yeah the update was about three
I think give or take if I recall
correctly around three yeah so yeah you
can go and try it right now if you have
it on PC go road hog for Mehta Road hogs
the ultimate metaphor everything didn't
get nerfed he's nerved he's buffed he's
all over the place I just know that Dave
Jewett are another one of our colleagues
in Europe love's a road hog and he is
sad cuz road hog is not so great now
that's that's a fair thing but again you
guys came them confirm or deny that for
me because apparently I don't play
enough well I know this is my account so
it's all on me
no no but apparently we didn't know the
Oasis thing so that's all me well I also
just don't play on those Maps
I love quick play and other random
things too much there you go why would I
say said name for loot boxes that's not
gonna get us loot boxes yeah that
doesn't do anything for me that's like
me saying your name without saying it
you know what I'm talking you know who
I'm talking about
mmm old man tey is out of the game
that's that's true salty salty I am too
salty now to play the game no DM with
single DM as a team there's deathmatch
of Bowl routine or a single variety
we're doing free-for-all now and then
we're gonna do some team deathmatch
we're gonna try some team stuff I don't
feel like more people are probably into
yeah that might be the case so we'll
check my sense it makes the roles a
little bit more interesting alright like
you can actually play off of each other
apart I wonder if I wonder if it it
probably does tell you like you don't
have enough healers oh god your tin cup
is not exactly to DPS a tank and a
healer what are you doing get out there
you go
yes suck he is - there's only deathmatch
mode currently in PTR but you
as you all are aware if it hits PTR
chances are it's gonna go live probably
in a few weeks they want to just
probably stress test it one check
balance you know balance testing and
then you know see what's broken try to
fix those things beforehand but usually
when it hits PTR it's usually in a very
playable state yeah obviously and they
just kind of fine-tune what they need to
before it comes out proper hey virus
says please play a Sombra I want to see
how she is in this mode she seemed
pretty decent at least yeah and she's
yes because she was hacking the not only
hacking you but also hacked all the hell
it was like super annoying big plays
with that but I'm not very good with
Sombra but I'll give it my best try
maybe maybe she's really good too for
like team team wise you know just
control the health deck controlling the
health packs it seems like a very very
big thing Ryan Costello saying anyone
who has a self heal is gonna be the meta
anyone who can stop themselves from
dying senior
Putin cake says our pun cake rather
doofus meta on deathmatch its doom fist
every day all day every day yeah maybe
they waited to release doofus like oh
man perfect we'll put the deathmatch
character with the deathmatch mode these
uh these wait times are a heck of a
thing could be people downloading
awesome hard to say cuz like it was
weird cuz like you had that long time
and then you got like instantly in the
idea the time you back down Riku what's
up seek the courage how goes it good to
see you yeah you're talking about
balance a little earlier to I'm
wondering how cuz this is all put into
arcade so I don't know if they're super
worried about Bell always you'd have to
make like weird character specific
changes just for this mode I feel if you
wanted to make it absolutely balanced
yeah I think that their focus or well my
opinion obviously but their focus will
probably be for competitive yeah and
then just having this as just another
mode you can play in arcade hopefully
it's not one of those like seasonal ones
just kind of stays so that there's just
kind of another mode to have him there
and like what does it hurt to have this
in arcade right yeah it's just there you
want to go and kill people
exactly I don't you know maybe this is a
good way to filter out all the people
who don't attack the objective they
don't go for there's another map the
horizon lunar colony and this is just
gonna put us on the regular map um all
right so we're gonna try Sombra give her
a go I wonder if so do you think TDM has
like a different set of maps and then
the free-for-all is only on shot so then
I think maybe they're heavily weighing
out Chateau now cuz its new but I did
see that they reworked some of the other
ways go he lured someone I might have to
switch to a healer because I know that
I'm not gonna do very well as Sombra but
I'll I'll end up making that switch
probably dan dan the jarate man yes this
is in arcade mode currently only look
what's rock climbing what is even rock
climbing in space seems to kind of
defeat the purpose doesn't it yeah I
mean you know it's it's all good so this
looks like it's just a sect like a
set-aside part of the map or be the
other team this is a good question I see
a blocked off area over here and I
wonder if but it says fight it does why
are we not fighting come on and fight me
ten minutes face me
nine minutes let me fight you please
I'll teleport through don't worry just
give it a go we'll find a way well over
this way in the back he's sneaky I see
good hacked oh did it
so Oh big monkeys behind you yeah I need
to not be here ok 1 verse 3 that means
three kills probably yeah we're alright
we're okay making a thing work we don't
gain the snipes
let's say we finally found a mode for
widow to be in wow I don't know that any
widow that can sleep any I'm into it oh
my goodness no thank you
hack that out and give me that those hot
envious strats oh he doesn't even see
you he doesn't he's got that he'll
though go whoa
should check out on the road hog still
be in there sup dude nice we played
thank you for the tip to hack and then
attack no I thought I could I thought I
could out dancing I was wrong the little
cheeky Jukes
yeah bit Bob I was corrected earlier
about jump pads on Oasis thank you
appreciate that appreciate the chat
keeping us honest follow me out listen
check all the time I love me I love it
that's what chat chats supposed to get
your back I've been playing a lot of
lawbreakers recently so this is like I'm
kind of like trying to adjust back to
overwatch because pretty much my
overwatch experience in the past couple
of days has oh and event started up I'm
gonna log on and get my boxes and then
I'm going to play lawbreakers yeah
that's fair very different why isn't it
66 hard to say it's a good question Oh
like get out of here with dad
granted they're both owned by Activision
but it's also interesting to see destiny
switch from six to four - yeah so there
has to be some type of logic or number
behind Wow unlucky some type of logic
behind the four view four versus 66 is
my guess could be totally wrong but
there's gotta be something there this is
what I think's always solo nice yeah we
got it up clean it up so you got a do
yeah you're pretty much like harass and
like yeah you know it's kind of
interesting how the way that you play
them and like other things still kind of
plays in yeah like still do some cool
like dumb flying things with somber
probably state I or get killed by
another song bro realized how good it
was
Oh
goodness si Senor pun cake said that
Jeff said in the developer update it was
66 so I haven't watched the update maybe
we just had like we match made in two
less people
oh hi no I said four before in the
tooltip hmm I wonder if it was
originally planned as 66 and then they
changed it or we have an older build
potentially I don't know hobble hard to
say if you die can you eat can you spawn
yes yeah if you hit space you respawn
brings you back instantly yeah please
don't cry he got buff has a second
charge oh can you switch I saw someone
else it's true where where we got like
uh there we go
oh oh this is not good for me in my eyes
someone tried young crap then yeah up
too late or just drop in from the sky
that's an interesting spawn point well
get to junk rat soon
it's Sala a test abate it will do junk
rat next time around
yeah we'll be junk rednecks this was a
lot of people wanting yeah I just saw
its junk rad stuff jump low not oh man
who got the plagues if Han Curie killing
it the hog the whole hog as it were oh
we got him in that small little room No
so what the lake I wasn't part of that
at all I don't even know what happened
the question is why did he not teleport
I'll give him the point that's fine
he did he did a good thing he got five
gold medals man it did a good thing yeah
I mean everybody's I'm he's on the other
team which makes me feel like I'm
betraying my people a bit you just gotta
give props to who did well exactly I got
silver for final blows that's or that in
a way which means I swooped in and I've
vultured everyone else's kills that's
what that means
road hog head I told you what was that
for free-for-all or was it for team
deathmatch all right we're going Junkers
chunk right my boy you you got the junk
instead
yeah yeah he had to it was a good event
too I love the Halloween one so here's
another thing now that we just had
Summer Games event yes right come back
yes still in emotion rather do you feel
that they're just gonna kind of do the
same modes Homer like season and just
like kind of like look at this
so yeah you got two charges right this
is this is a heck of a thing now I'm
gonna do it
what's it to ya I got two I can put two
down you blow them both up at the dang
that's nasty yeah right
junkie junkie times that's a good change
I'm into it
yeah I don't know man some people
complained about scary things fast
yeah he has a really good tendency to be
in the game and not actually be in the
game
just kind of like shoot stuff downrange
and then everyone dies just like you're
not even I like okay can I clear this
can I can I get it all the way down
there from downtown omit does it get rid
of the other one oh you know I would
assume it blow both up right cuz it's
not yeah you don't have your clicker out
it's like one two Sombra not like this
come on your soldier gotta lay some
traps down can't let that Sabra oh hello
I don't know what's happening oh yeah go
to get it boys on the ground asleep good
night uh-oh damn got the hacker ready I
guess so ooh just like that yep you be
in the game when you're not actually in
the game got him oh man we're all boys
that were they were they going did they
just go junk right cuz of you I possibly
I mean I don't want to say I'm evolving
the medicine oh I'm still evolving the
meta this is only a third game get out
of here with that
give her the mines oh it was it was mid
travel yes
there but it's still uh Bernard M says
road Hawk Buffy heels while walking I
noticed that actually when in the the
post game for the last okay he was
walking around in healing I don't want
to pull it you know I know you know
you're gonna camp them right I just I'll
just keep throwing things down there
it's just as good almost lucio get out
of here by himself sombras back over
here play joke at um I'll get on it for
you man junk ride is okey and so
annoying and he's getting another buff
not like this as gonna rim not like this
well there was a good question I do not
know if the mind still do 120 each that
that's a good sign that still needs to
be done I would need chat to tell me if
that is the case or not oh yeah
come on soldier get out of here boy yeah
yeah like that ah all right let's see
here you heard it all so apparently as
trap damage got buff really I don't know
let's put that over there oh oh yeah
give them the business gonna I heard a
junk right yelling over there you got
one too you know I'm just gonna let her
rip let's see what happens go over the
top oh oh oh
spider-man it kind of can go run let's
take out the killers whatever that's
fine it's not a big enough group for me
I'll just do it
take out someone who ripped I got buff
too faster and no time while climbing
walls Jesus everyone just jumped right
it's time to play the Australian
characters it seems dude hit that
cricket skin is pretty legit though yeah
that cricket skin is it's I I didn't
notice the leg until someone actually
went out somewhere oh and we trap but I
don't see anyone trapped I don't I don't
think that's what you think it means
we'll play roll call soon well do will
do road hog next man basically just will
keep rolling as people are telling us
like a CH notes have missed people and
they're actually way better than we
thought before yeah it's good time to
have that chat right
I love the fact that I can kill 100
that's fire in the hole
yeah it is from behind run Ana get out
of there
no no oh you guys are one bad wave yeah
poncho don't do as far as lightning you
guys haunted Oh
Hanzo don't do it Hamza you find too
close to the Sun oh good guy yeah get
got oh oh it's not the 20 it's the 25 I
guess
oh I think it's the 30 yeah 30 is for
Team Deathmatch okay
Oh they've got so much shield there know
we lost drop the mines baby wait for my
oh my have to come off cooldown oh oh
you got hacked
yeah I didn't see that I thought I saw
three of them up I'm like oh this is it
but it was not it as it turns out oh hey
junk rat by junk rat get me in a you
mean a safe place here no Sombra it's
only two mines guys yeah only only two
all right here we go here we go oh do
bleh give it to you there we go give
them the do bleh get out of here give
her another one
Oh couldn't quite do it that would have
been hot right that would have been a
hot game oh oh this is a perfect
oh come on I get trapped one of you - oh
yeah I like it stuck closed off that a
little bit area and then do thing do a
thing oh yeah
no right out of the martyrdom called
duty for all over again oh hey remember
how much I hated that it was like
literally the worst the first time we
all were introduced to it it was and we
watched all of your die you know it's
catchy Erte why weren't you on camera on
the lobby yesterday cuz I was sick as I
had mentioned earlier I had the sickness
you know what can you do but here's a
point maybe you can do it kind of like
how
I used to be able to put symmetric
turrets down and wait for the cooldown
to be up to put down the third mine it
makes sense Tommy makes a lot of sense
that doesn't make sense you're looking
out good I'll do it you know for four
gold medals oh wow I'm gonna Kanye it
myself
Kanye spot ah don't cry counters
everyone I'm gonna call it
I am the Frog the other mode is just
free-for-all death match up to eight
people basically it was it first of
twenty so I think team is first a 31st
to 2007 FFA yeah that's what I meant the
new map is on for FFA yes
shuttle shuttle and then I can't say the
other word I can't either we're going on
the chateau and I call it that and leave
road hog here we go
yes I've been told there's been a jump
pad on Oasis thank you it's it's very
important that we all know yeah we go
just in case everyone else didn't know
now you guys know you know but yeah good
times just so you guys know we're trying
out the new deathmatch modes there's a
free-for-all as well as a team
deathmatch and we were playing currently
team deathmatch which is 401 I can heal
while I move that's crazy
don't forget your hook your best that's
it punch of oh I didn't do the punch I'm
sorry it's not least a tank fun fast Wow
which is weird it's weird cuz he's he's
good and I know he's good yeah but I
recently actually started playing diva
and I realize how much I was cutting
into her she's pretty annoying we
weren't even in a game over just like a
real game but it there weren't enough
people all right after this team
deathmatch we'll do we'll go back to
free-for-all so you guys can see that
yeah the new map the chateau they don't
even save a second word I just call it
chateau deathmatch yeah little like a
teaser screen yeah IRISA got a buff
bigger barrier faster bullets these are
all things I want more let's okay
the notes will just start reading off
the patch notes in between uh do a
dramatic reading of the patch now that
would be you you got the ERISA was
buffed I don't have much bigger shields
now
oh my IRISA what large shields you have
okay how to participate yeah we I've
already told Chad how to do that if you
want to know both modes will play out on
a selection of maps from our existing
pools Hani mourra horizon lunar colony
temple of Anubis will sky dorado
eyshan Wald Hollywood Kings row and then
TDM only Black Forest castilo echo point
Antartica and necropolis there's a new
deathmatch map chateau gila Guillard
hero updates I wish I could do dramatic
reading sorry cam that's okay you got
this junk rat I believe that you're mine
you know hold the two mines rip tired
tired movement speed has been increased
30% there's no longer a time limit win
white awesome great no sorry I got
distracted it's okay there's a lot of
crazy stuff going on right now look at
that he'll mid mu I it's real weird
thing you get used to because like get
out of the way and like be able to stand
still but I don't right don't forget
your shift
yes that's what you need anyways let's
see Arisa fusion driver projectile speed
increased 20% as mentioned by check
protective barrier barrier size
increased by 20% barrier shape has been
changed to allow for more coverage from
enemies that are below the barrier take
a little nap while we relax for a bit I
guess whoa hello business
given the bit oh no he was right there
Reaper
he was basically gone
that's when you gotta give him the hook
hook them from hook took them food from
downtown all the way downtown right
there
Oh oh my god did they make and his
slipping darts bigger I think you're
just a big time I'm just a big target
boy oh my god I'm still alive heal while
walking chase that doom fist while you
heal yes all right doctor reading yeah
road hog take a breather can now be used
while moving damage taken while healing
has been reduced by 50% that seems
pretty good oh my god come on bad I'm
gonna uninstall in a second here
get out give her the hook all right
there you go John jeez oh man that was
no pressure
we're all touch-and-go there for a
second no he's not here bad I need help
and by touch-and-go I mean there was no
touching or going it was just a whole
lot of dancing yes uh Widowmaker
grappling hook cooldown has been reduced
from 12 seconds to eight men of mine
effected targets are now visible through
walls oh wow to you as we don't make our
own oh yeah get over here
oh but go to sleep I'm just gonna relax
for a second here is just wow goodness
she's dead now and that's all matters my
boys in yatta I don't care who did the
kill I just care that she's gone get out
of here it's a speed hacker just it's
the pro engine I've ever seen and the
dealer walked in front of it just march
right towards him ran away from me
what come in cooker there's a lot of bad
guys oh yeah oh you just got over your
head huh yeah it happens the best of us
yeah don't forget with a right-click you
get that long-range one you got
alternate fire yeah don't worry guys he
doesn't play road hog that much just
room to the life of overwatch and what
it means to have this many characters
it's also a very convenient excuse for
when I don't do great whoa whoa whoa I
gave you the bailout and you just throw
yourself back under the bus sometimes
you've got to live under that bus to
look like to properly know how
everything goes the team deathmatch
currently Oscar scooped with our scorp
sorry Oscar score is four before
oh yeah yeah given the butyl
wall-to-wall to the window to the wall
this is what nope nope not going there
there is a censored version of the song
that's no fun yeah but see there's a
bunch of bug fixes that I'm not gonna
read because they're not exciting that's
not exciting so the hero stuff I have
read out again PTR though so hard to say
if these things will make it into actual
proper game but those are what are
currently in the game and their prior
testing it I'm sure there's gonna be a
lot of people crying about junk rat oh
yeah probably this guy doesn't know I
use look either oh yeah perfect just
like I planned it BLAP BLAP hook I'm in
kokum is copyrighted by Muse ELQ merch
okay my bad i just i'm just reading chat
man I'm just reading chat didn't know it
was copyright them hook them and book
them there oh there you go that's
alright how about that we'll take that
one cuz I'm running out of words that oh
yes the drop down it was kind of worth
but not really not really
it looks cool I'm sure it's hook um and
look them I don't know you wish that
joke redhead to bear traps to I don't
know about that I wish Juncker had
infinite bear traps she's come out
everywhere rubber-type that's a good a
good name
this guy okay look it's me your boy
getting shot from behind by three people
hit yeah I don't blame them anytime okay
there you go triple triple trip it's a
play of the game that's all right you
want to try a little so you guys can see
that and probably so that we can check
out chateau yeah yeah
this shot oh thank you guys for tuning
in we stream normally every day at 11
a.m. today was a slightly different day
because we thought this was going to
come out around 11:00 turns out it came
out at 1:00 so now we're streaming here
and we appreciate all of you guys being
here with us telling us what's
copyrighting and what's not apparently
it's great that we're able to keep our
copyrights in check exactly so if you
haven't subscribed or followed us on
twitch and YouTube you guys should do
that so you guys get notified of when we
go live and so that you can join us in
copyright infringement exactly that way
we're all in together that means you
guys are an accessory yeah
congratulations
we're not the only ones liable get
ranked get good get god so we gotta go
with hook up my book um hook them in
Bochum cuz we can't do the other one
this is the fun part where we sit here
and wait and there's no estimated time I
get to read all these other ones hook up
and fist them hook them and so come you
know what we'll do a wrist net hook up
and miss them that's true I want to see
how big original she'll do it we'll do
it a free-for-all we're not afraid
heck yeah we're not afraid of the tank
messag ago tank meta we're evolving the
meta constantly on the stream live in
front of you we don't even know what the
meta well according to your ad it's
doofus I feel like anyone could just be
like AUSA
thing where you kill people but doofus
put them in there when is taken I get
around how many streams
I just don't play anymore man oh we're
doing what yeah it's a pitch 1/2 10 my
goodness I'll watch out oh here we go
oh okay get back over there Oh diva
doesn't know what to do cuz you shoot so
fast right oh my goodness these bullets
I don't even know what he's doing he's
like exploiting the mat I feel bad don't
feel bad
we want the dope I mean I'm killing but
I feel Oh junk that
where anna is a pretty big barrier yeah
right
Ola trace hey sir could be pretty good
for this oh my goodness a skillful
tracer yeah it when a tracer is good you
know they're good can you give we've
been asked to give a tour through the
chateau we can do what let's join the
stiva
all right let's do it well draw the
demon we'll do an adventure all right so
we've got this lovely view out here onto
this lake beautiful where are you good
that's not fair I can't follow you
you're gonna die
Road hogs over there in the library some
books hey dude we're trying to check
what are you doing jerk truck get
Malayan rainbow you would I agree what a
lame rainbow all right so we're in the
Blue Room so a Blue Room you know seems
and cool stuff and out to a courtyard of
stitch where we killed Eva before or
wave to them what's up
good to see ya mm-hmm more beautiful
views out here yeah our town is that one
of these places are probably like I can
I could walk yeah that makes sense
who do you think chateau this is let me
see you say it's oh it's the name we
can't pronounce
I got excuse me that was like a talk
burp Chateau Gaylord is located near an
NC in southeastern France for hundreds
of years it was the estate of the
influential influential Guillard family
until it gradually fell into disrepair
after the family's power waned in the
decades after the revolution recently
the Chateau has found a new owner the
Talon agent the talent agent Widowmaker
who has returned our family's ancestral
home oh so this is make senses
widow-makers house look how creepy it is
but all these bottles everywhere wine
wine wine nine France oh my goodness you
love those puns
I do the puns are great my erisa
gameplay is not trying to look at the
city where we're trying to oh yeah you
gotta give her give him the watchman
call it give him that
get back here you Wow he killed pretty
fast
yeah he can also heal while I'm oh no
you gotta give them the the clencher mm
the thing yeah yes for everyone else
Oasis does have a jump pad fireplace
with no fireplace that's the fire
yes some sort of a family crest up on
the wall the painting some cool
paintings nice some more boxes back down
there there's not too much to this place
it doesn't actually every Lola page oops
I'm not gonna diva diva just go ahead oh
wait oh just oh yeah oh yeah disrespect
this is her house I can't I can't be too
picky
you know her house her rules jump at
action again I wonder you can get up
there I've got to be able to probably
like as Widowmaker or something - nope
no thank you
smell let you kind of do your thing over
there I'm gonna head this way they're
gonna shoot me and I should probably
just kill them yes I probably should
just get back into killing mode I think
yeah yeah we're good tours over he's
hired have been getting murdered while
trying to give you guys a tour
clearly there's guests it's cool you
guys should check it out on the PTR and
PC if you can actually I think if you
have like you don't have to actually
have a copy I think you do it really
think you do
so remember oh oh no maybe you do need I
think we'll do have to have the game I
believe no I want you guys tell me
what's up I think that you have to have
the game too in order to download PTR I
could be wrong and maybe you guys can
tell me I'm wrong
wait would it be the first time today if
we find out that anyone can get in there
and do it without actually having the
game that's pretty exciting
yeah otherwise it's just kind of
whatever I guess yes that she I think
that she'll has a quicker cooldown it
feels like - or maybe I'm just doing
whatever with it could be could be
possibly also I don't forget to use your
what should we call it the god I gotta
look at the no that thing yeah use that
do Anadyr you haha
just like it like on cue we got oh you
got yeah 97% I wonder how that okay so
that's it that's an interesting look it
doesn't count as a kill yet it doesn't I
don't think so it counts as an assist
oh that sucks so like if you get last
hitted then it's like saying it's yours
that seems that seems like an odd way to
do it but it should be like damage dealt
hey we're giving it another Melissa
York's go in you targeting you know you
should have shifted on him
oh yeah we're not afraid we'll do it
I just knocked him off I tried it didn't
work bounced off the wall I don't know
if a wrist is great for this da da
saying you do need the game to enter the
PTR okay
that's unfortunate I got can use my
heroes to I believe next time I don't
think yeah thingy
wait for me yep sweet justice
shoot me Reaper kill me so hit okay I
change characters Oh try because I'm
kind of curious to you know what let's
let's give into the meta those people
okay so you did not get that killing no
okay so you got the assist yeah that's
kind of weird
yeah have you been playing two fists no
not very much yeah uh-oh oh oh and you
can't knock him off cuz they hit the
button that the halts said no you don't
go anywhere else gave me the matumbo
life stay here so I I did kind of mess
around in training a bit to see like you
can like cancels moves yet by doing
shots still not good at that
ti mind design not sure when it's coming
to ps4 not sure when it's gonna come to
life but usually it's like a couple
weeks but that's just guesswork
yeah oh yes see it's it the way that the
killing is set up is like every other
free-for-all but every character has
different howling Reaper I'm so good
it's it's weird cuz it's unreliable I
don't know it's yeah I don't know how
like this one's that sounds weird
because I feel like it's last hit yeah
cuz it wasn't damage done cuz you didn't
97 damage apparently to like one
character and then didn't get the kill
credit for it
and then I was trying to see if you got
so don't think I got my my Reaper match
before yeah your might be okay
combat mercy activated I think Mercy's
probably bad and free-for-all if was she
had a way to heal herself but she seems
pretty good in team deathmatch because
if what you what you said is true which
is a based on I think something you said
you read which is that if she revives it
actually takes points away yeah I'm the
overall score that seems pretty good
need not be outside that's the bad worst
place you can do it I'm working it
Spider Man there was a McCree behind me
come on there we go
no I went for the he doesn't heal by
picking up orbs anymore right okay I was
like I was like I need to pick up the
orb really quick and maybe I can turn
around here Devin's gonna happen again
God some mess again you gotta win this
there's healthy our knee to your right
to blame rainbow I can't even hang I
can't hand at all I see hints of a Joey
versus Ben showdown it's it's probably
gonna be very heavily in Joey's favor
I based on what I've seen so far I'm
sorry Ben
no no don't have to agree it's yeah yeah
everyone's dead
no no tracer get out of here what this
isn't where you want to be I don't know
it's not where I want to be at all wow I
can't believe that actually went by the
monument and got you still yeah you know
how it goes I'm gonna i'm trying to stay
inside oh switch topic oh go get these
kills
the Genji birth Kenji but you get side
busted by the repeat Eve's he comes in
and just ruins everyone's day whoa boy
this like her that charger watch map is
very reliant on knowing where the health
packs are yes oh hi what's up everyone
oh hello oh hi NCR order my neck longer
than both of yours okay I'm guessing
like a giraffe then right I guess I like
that your neck is longer than ours this
dream is just about jump pads now look
okay it's a very important thing that
everyone notices jump has oh I did dude
that would have been so crazy if you
could have just time that but I always
go for the shoe because like I want I
want like the flat shut down yeah but
remember this is free for all you got
for yourself this is this is a different
game you know yeah you got to play it
differently there's no objective here I
can't sit on a cart there are no
objectives it's all about the kills here
all about the Benjamins baby exactly
where hold on I'm gonna try this now cuz
I'm curious about up here you got to be
able to use oh it's just those by it's
just to pass through oh I'm just gonna
peace out for a second he's gonna follow
you no he definitely isn't he's going to
shoot make up I was like where's the
nearest health I know there's one down
here alright I don't get the the thing
that's like under the timer though I
guess you're oh okay first is that guy
with seven and your fifth with five yeah
this is fine ma'am it's been a slow
match so far actually yeah
oh you dad go hashbrowns take a seat
like me some hashbrowns that's breakfast
the swoop on that health pack was a was
a good call I don't know why you ran two
words you though I think he also wanted
the notes back
I'll take a double that that's okay
that's good
that was a good die die die moment I
like it all the chats probably salty
about it but I've owned it all about it
reapers reap results the best thing
because it's just so stand next to
someone and kill them all
[Music]
get it out of here
but don't mean actually like get out of
here come back so I can kill you or what
tracer kill you that's fine
but silly is that oh yes get out okay
you got the kill that was worth in my
opinion that's worth like in in a giant
mess you just gotta focus whoever you
started otherwise someone's gonna take
it from you I mean in in tedium if we're
basing it only on scores in the worst
case you want to at least trade in the
worst case Oh God
doofus and to the left me too just to
the right maybe it's the thing but you
have tools it's just that if you can't
see him it's kind of annoying yeah we
did the math we do the science 120
equals 130 it's all good still you know
I don't know if that kind of feel so bad
for him though it does oh no it didn't
give you the kiss scene he definitely
outplayed me buddy I Cal so well played
himself at the same time yeah but if you
didn't get a kill for that then he
actually bent it oh nice [ __ ] that's
what I'm talking about time to mention
to a wall yo where the hell did you go
out of here oh look it's another one
already uh
this is not where I want to be at all no
no actually junk grants seems pretty
good with a double mind now yeah I think
about it for this he just doesn't want
to be outside yeah outside is just a bad
place to be
oh that bad no baby I do gotta you gotta
go go spawn you gotta go it's true it's
okay oh no I walked right back
TDM actually Shaun Johnson was four
before it wasn't actually
66 yeah I've been told by chat that Jeff
daddy Jeff said 6p6 but when we played
it just now as for before huh agency 27
in the overwatch actual chat says effing
doom fists same not going to come in
here
vo gaming this is currently out on PTR
on PCs so if you have it you can play oh
now you're learning we're doing it we're
evolving we're good now here it is
they haven't seen our final form oh yeah
I'm not gonna hit that for him I'm not
gonna do that
this is alright this guy just oh he hit
his though you got it you gotta play
some some mind games here well clean it
up get back what's gone now it's good
knowing you don't get the yeah it was
all Farrah whoa he wants that ass not
today he's out of cooldown whoa jeez I
like my squad I actually don't like that
yeah I think that it should be the most
damage done hear me out okay I've got
this and I got a hot take listening
overwatch was not designed for
deathmatch oh yeah of course not I mean
simple geometry I mean I still actually
I think it's cool like I know I look
good it's there I don't know how much I
would actually play of this but like I
mean now that it's out I definitely
would I like it it's an option I don't
know if I would like I only play
overwatch for deathmatch well do you
feel like the team deathmatch is I think
I def much is a little more viable
because you can do a little bit of team
stuff with you because that's team I
agree thank you cuz that's you know what
that would be like that's like arena
Yeah right like wow arena oh you got it
oh you went to a corner or he'll come
back in I don't know okay thank you ORN
I got the kill
oh you did yeah I won't let through yet
we're a second place baby Reed
bring it back behind back OOP oh hi
you guys should each other for a bit I'm
gonna steal your kills I like the
thought I mean I feel like you got to
kind of play it that way baby demon if
you have PC you need to download the PTR
by selecting it's in the region select
which is then PTR oh this is not what I
want at all I'm just gonna leave you
over there have a fun time oh you got to
do it yes there we go yeah that's sweet
Mele see you back there no he's shooting
from up here oh yes wham-o yep yep we're
learning we got it we got it you're
definitely evolving we're in there
Lucas temp temp in the air sorry if I
put your last name yes it oh yeah yeah
there we go there we go
oh we're catching uh we were catching
we're getting out of those box so it
looks like the the loot box reward for
placing then top three maybe instead of
just having yeah we look at the
stipulation I'm sure this happened
because I know there's they're offering
a loop box for winning cuz you two
different hit boxes whatever okay but I
definitely didn't get first and I got a
loop box this seems like a pretty decent
far I'm at no good just hang out in that
one spot and just do it at 17 and fifty
eight assists I feel bad for lame rave
oh he has 12 assists
yeah see you did better than one one
that's how I'd look I mean it's not bad
mix it up yeah get a good good balance I
think that they could turn Team
Deathmatch into something I could see
that more more so than free-for-all
free-for-all is obviously disapper fun
motor but no it's like an expanded team
deathmatch almost like six I want to be
able to have more flexibility in like
actually building a team than like so
right now it's like Final Fantasy 14
where you have to have two DPS and like
a healer and attack you don't know the
meta and call it right now right now
okay the meta is Final Fantasy 14 party
status
okay Tommy Perkins Black Watch Karen
Tino Moya
hubby Tom
Perkins crazy Zeigler dan dan the Jura
jarate man Tom well finger thank you
guys yes top four for the box I try to
get I did it because you guys all said
the same thing
but did you hear that there's a jump
head on Oasis yeah I did
apparently I said Lucas's name false but
no problem I'm just not gonna say your
last name Lucas what does it mean name
of the man shot Toki lard
yeah I think it's more like that it's
I'm sure there's some sort of weird like
pronounciation to it that I can't wrap
my mind around but it's there it appears
more people playing the hot free-for-all
yeah which makes sense because of the
map but I just for your Joe I'll give
McCrea try although it's not gonna go
you know most-played Reinhart definitely
in a second oh it's probably rowing
stinner mercy because the way that I
play overwatch is I want to play
Reinhardt and then I see that we don't
have a healer or we don't have a DPS and
then I played you said your top for
healing and tank probably at I toss up
between like soldier and Reaper that's
fair because soldiers just got too much
versatility yeah just so these shoes
these these this games type or these
game types are not for you maybe yes
Reinhard we can do a healer at some
point too like the riding hardwood I
feel like reinhardt's not that great and
44 yeah like I don't see why you he's
like an objective get crazy do a little
McCree maybe mercy maybe you should try
mercy I say we might have someone who
needs to switch to a healer and this
this man Dan look at all these level
ones and you called us out I can't
believe this they're all probably like
level 30s or 40s on theirs too just like
what is this where all my unlocks okay
quotes hit the [ __ ] baby you gotta go
goes for him that's is the truth nor
take any pity stream did you see how he
evolved it sure we and like we learned
we adapted we baited the do fist punch
like man so many big plays it was just
it was a good time overall you know even
though he got second
I'm having a weird time wrapping my mind
around like how they're just cordoned
off areas that's so I'm like no one
fights here ever well you do if you're
crazy and you really want to contest
them in between the places like no
reason this is like fighting between the
points in ABMA simple geometry right
into my chest is the deathmatch the most
kills yes yeah in team deathmatch first
at 30 and free-for-all first to 20 we're
on this one but the interesting thing in
free-for-all is it's about last hits and
not about damage done yeah should even
get like partial kills or anything you
get the assists in your actual like
stats but they don't mean anything yeah
towards the end results because we found
a way to like math it out and kind of
like get out of here you oh my god so
hey then how how do you like your McCree
do you like it when he's choking because
that's exactly what that was anyway I'm
doing this for you guys this is not for
me no no clearly yeah got a torque we
are building that like the skin because
he was never a robot arm oh my god get
out of here he smells your fear he does
he knows he got out get that out of here
this guy he's being real cheeky look I
assumed estarán they were looking at you
I'm not gonna lie then yeah it's not
it's not doing that I think you need to
swap off I'm gonna do you the sir I'm
gonna definitely do it after this don't
cry asking what level are you non PTR
I'm awake in the 70s or 80s by felt long
while as same user eighties - I honestly
haven't played too much I play a little
bit each oh that was a nice mm I shot
know I play a bit like each time there's
not gonna vent but I don't really play
as much as I you still have a healer
we're good for some reason I'm gonna
Winston go on Winston could be viable I
think also you don't have to aim with
them so yes
exactly that's how I felt about some
Metro Oh surprise oh she's ran away oh
there's another Winston Oh monkey monkey
on monkey in action Planet of the Apes I
think you're gonna lose though yeah
wasn't a bad place increase well done
it's a pretty good memory plays games
it's just like most other casual
overwatch players everyone only has a
few good heroes and you know what that's
just how it goes and I would I would say
the same thing if you asked me to play
McCree I'd probably look like how Ben
did oh yeah but we're gonna get this guy
definitely and then I don't have
everyone chase music all about a quick
you jumping too hard you gotta bring it
in Winston it definitely is too like
knowing about where all health is
because I am I cannot count on zenyatta
to always heal me oh yeah definitely
jeez oh yeah give him the zapper finish
him off there we go hold left click to
win oh he's almost dead
get back here dude I'm not done with you
for I am gone oh it's a cook tape who
kill their yeah big heels yeah we like
that drink that health oh ha ha wants to
get zapped okay maybe I'm not in a good
place for that at all no you're not
there's a Widowmaker down here she's
grabbed the health oh you got poisoned
oh I didn't even see the outside of the
screen I just saw your life taking out
Kel'Thuzad loves him some monkey on
monkey action who weeds oh yeah who's
the boss now
yeah it's not me his brother there he is
dr. Angela allies Zeigler Ziegler looks
so fun can't wait to play yep we take at
home sue and you two can play a
deathmatch oh my god that Widow is going
to work yeah she is I I feel like this
is the perfect place for Widow to
actually like like get get what she's
owed you know
by getting a map but get it beginning a
space where she can just do what she
does best and that's killed that's a
good point can you go into spawn spawn
points we can create or don't shoot me
I'm trying to do a thing here
just wait for it nope you can't no it's
all blocked off
thanks for nothing's solid walls wrapped
it up here we are get her set slow
motion oh he swapped to Reaper heart
counter sometimes you got oh he's not
having it unlock your perks and you're
all that'd be an interesting way to do
it like look if they did like oh if
anyone played counter-strike like one
point six a long time ago in the you
like unlock more features for your
character yeah that'd be interesting
they have access to their own stuff like
with with Warcraft and I'm the only
person still on my team everyone got out
there like got back to FFA here we go
yeah yeah fun times currently playing
the new modes in PTR the public test
realm only available on PC sorry console
don't know when it's actually gonna come
out safe assumptions by a couple weeks
yeah but we'll see this was usually
pretty good it's like one or two weeks
usually when the app on PTR and it goes
live unless something's like majorly
broken or something like that you know
I'm gonna try yeah I'm gonna give him
mercy oh I literally have never had the
skin equipped since that event it's
always like this was a 3000 skin T right
yeah yeah or maybe I anyway the most
important mercy skin is the witch mercy
skin and that's the only one I should
ever have equip yeah that one was a
weird event I am I mean I liked the mode
I just thought the skins we're kind of
lacking for how much they wanted for
them because they didn't seem that
different yeah you know so go it's this
character but younger McCree don't see
why diva you're you're too young well
this is not a good place to be
let's close but no cigar yeah
and we'll also get to see if that
negative oh wow you can get a negative
in this that's interesting
so if you suicide it's a negative do you
please why I choose shielding up for
bullet Cacnea oh you're crazy sir you
got to get in there sometimes still
crazy but you know best I mean I like
your your your vote of confidence
alright so in theory one
oh I'm not healing twitch itself twitch
yet little person named twitch TV up
there nice baby
she's even wearing purple it's perfect
what are the odds
what's up little cartoon theorists
Junior well played well played black
Dave that's how it goes yeah have you
had this rock just yeah this is me this
is my rock rock someone kill that guns
you please no I will do that I think I
saw the point roll back I'd have to
check the playback the the replay the
replay oh oh I got stuck no gotta get
that job what's that Bob Jones see if
only I had a jump had this would be a
lot better
where's my jump pad on Hanah Maura
Blizzard don't pad everything jump pad
everything well they did say if the jump
pads were like people like the whole
this is a bad place that they would try
to do no okay he missed you bull ah damn
it's too late I didn't know what maybe
maybe mercy isn't the best place I'm
gonna switch to Lucio after this I feel
like with Lucy I'll be able to like do
more instead of just like straight-up
nah dude that heal life
oh all right what skin do we got on our
Lucy oh this is good oh just a punt amok
see it oh it's not an interesting time
to bring the hat on RC so I play with a
Razer Naga yeah and I'm using the
buttons yeah so I'm I'm semi struggling
to hit the button sometimes got it fair
oh god it's gonna try to stay in a
corner really quick until that's gone oh
did you get her no oh you gotta get out
yeah do do something do some dancing on
these the heck is my team all right it
come here you they're just running away
from me
come back goodbye I don't want to deal
with you now have you guys had an office
tournament at GameSpot no but for the
longest time I was joking about us
versus UK just because they actually
play they play a long day but I'm not
afraid of them
I think I think the u.s. would be able
to take them I would actually play the
game again just to beat them just to
just to get back in just to get back
into it just to beat them that would be
a pretty motivating reason it'd be a
good time yeah would not lie would not
be afraid it has do it normal overwatch
though I mean like I mean yes that
normal overwatch but I mean like not not
just oh you mean like okay something
like either payload or take me back to
the overwatch that I know come back here
so you're saying you're not digging this
thing it's interesting I don't
I like deathmatch but I like it like in
almost any other I'm all about that
deathmatch life it's kind of here leave
me alone get him get him get him get him
why didn't you get him I had to get him
Oh No
you can't climb that I was trying to
like wiggle my way back to the wall to
like ride back up these are the things
hi red widow 1 2 2 3 hi three times so
uh hello oh nice
ooh he's got the good radiant skin I'm
all about that I bought that skin even
though I don't play again do just like I
bought anime Reinhardt even though I
don't play that much Reinhardt though
there's a gun
yeah that one was piece I want it but I
can't use it over gold heart no I need
more anime skins of my life
have you seen like divas for hots no no
so divas got like literally every skin
that she hasn't hots is like a million
times better than any other one she has
here surprising what about police diva
sir police TV was good it's the best
diva skin undoubtedly but um she has
like half her skins are like anime
references yeah they should bring
something here that they should they
really should look we're capturing the
points just kidding so there's no point
here there's no point notice me senpai
what's up Xander robe let's how are you
oh hello how the it's unfortunate a
little bit it's okay though wow that guy
is like use this all oh boy we good
nice this is okay this is aa new meta
new meta we got stayed together as four
together on top of illusio yes Xavier
Xavier Rosado we have deathmatch now
team deathmatch twitch TV got the play
of the game you're currently on twitch
TV twitch.tv slash GameSpot check us out
there live stream every day at 11 a.m.
Wednesday is the lobby check it out
Monday's has been Pub de Mondays Tuesday
is usually new games with me and
somebody Thursday is usually Triforce
Thursday or something Peter Robb related
yeah and Friday so far has been a new
one called game dump and with Joey and
John we will see but that's currently
how we're going to stuff all the time I
think we're both doing pretty well
Xander thanks for asking yeah hang in
there oh yeah this mode is out currently
on PTR I'm PC only the two of you are
meta we haven't even thought about the
Torbjorn meta yet okay Calvin's odd
you're opening up new doors new
possibilities you want to go free for
all the end this I should show you one
more free-for-all Oh No Madara in the
shadow madara's in the shadow would she
have my daughter no you died though oh
that's why there's dang or did I spoil
can you play some play any character and
free-for-all which is cool but not I
mean you can play them but you probably
shouldn't there are certain ones that
will do better free-for-all than others
so much you might do a summation might
alright you just find your way back to
your camping spot yeah and just kind of
sit in a corner and just kind of watch
them click look just sit at a corner and
just hold down the button and as people
walk past
I don't want to do Torbjorn I want to
think about this like properly here
should we should we give Sombra going
frou-frou because we dinner in in team I
don't know I think you should play
whoever you think you're gonna do best
with we're ending the stream with this
one buddy oh shoot I know big pressure
right here you wanna do yes I the god in
here
you're not the god Medora if you are
slain how can you be the god
you don't exist oh yes mail day may you
like me might might be my baby they is
they she's got she's got really good
stuff going on come on just give me that
kill okay just give me that kill oh yeah
give me that kill make a nice walk I
probably should shouldn't I probably he
lit up like a snowman and then you
they'll never know you're there and then
boom just I'm back in the game
boom I think anyone that can heal oh
yeah know that saved you from the thing
actually it did actually am oh oh that's
pretty smart though they backed up
that's fine that hot honey go out
somewhere else and we're come back
around McCree Metta hey maybe it's I
feel like it's I feel like McCree needs
to like to be on a bigger map for me oh
yeah get frozen begun take a seat well
wente give me this health did she does
speak Mandarin though yeah it's not
Cantonese know what let's just keep
running laps around this this okay yeah
I do yeah they'll never know what hit
them
exactly I'm getting a good rhythm will
just catch people as we walk past Oh
true mail it we are getting lip BAM
here it is the whoa custom a you ever
did oh yeah they're both scared of me do
you blame them loose oh you son you
though it's uh it's a fun time fun time
like recess
oh yes no don't let him steal it I feel
like yeah I feel like he done stole zit
it's fun we saw the fries we knew I had
it it was oh man let's be a second-place
tie here yeah whoa
good night see you later thanks for
dropping by oh yeah yeah yeah side bus
oh yeah side bus it's frozen the middle
of healing the side bus oh whoa time to
heal
stay frosty I'm back up here in a sec
see you later
we're good - next time as am a pro tip
you can just drop your ice ball right
away - you because you know he's gonna
pre-fire you yeah how much do you play
me she's not a bad one have your third
highest played to be honest gonna hate
oh I'm a is BAE I picked her as a joke
like when the game first came out and
then I realized she's like the ultimate
trol character and I've loved everything
about it yep there's health right behind
you - we'll just we'll just you know
we'll cap it off cuz it's not gonna I'm
gonna do everything oh hey sold you're
good to see you again come back smart
boy this guy's smart like nah I'm in
your narrow ass [ __ ]
there it is we're definitely not pro
players oh god are we even close to good
players I would say I'm average I'm a
very average player but I would never
tell the UK that I'm a god I'm God's
here
I turned down multiple offers to join
professional teams what I I didn't want
health benefits and 50,000 a year I'll
forget essential prize earnings come in
here what is going on
nothing no junk rat tire going off maybe
is the Makri meta and it's easy nagi
mmm oh well show him come here I'll show
him no no no yeah oh my god - close
wha nothing solid in that water snow oh
no well down there that's one you got a
beta oh okay he's dead now awkward yeah
someone's got to be behind there we go -
my careers right now no I can't I can't
make the jump
that's a good question Christmas
probably not
oh yeah I like it there we go someone's
following me yeah they are I think it's
the same person who shot me going up
behind the thing come here you know of
course the jump pads you hear that
they're on Oasis - oh I have the triple
M mains says Medora maimie korean mercy
those are pretty good it's not a bad bad
group of people really bad real sketch
it's already lost him oh he's over there
get out I'm gonna feel really quick good
idea yeah yeah eat some McCree we're
definitely trying come here
get off oh I like that that was high
just like an anime fight up on top of
the tower was on cooldown I was trying
to oh god I wasn't cool down but I it's
trying it's all good it's all good it's
like that ice block that hot major ice
block when in doubt always ice block
don't do it not like this oh we good
it's gonna chill for a bit
grab this health that I hope is here yes
may is BAE that's right Alex Berkowitz
oh yeah didn't see it even know I was
there what you gonna do I'm gonna miss I
want to miss and get killed that might
be the worst thing that's happened all
stream
to be honest what we call it choke we
hand only Oh
besides the Makri one there's a one
fight going on no okay yeah it's no one
else will come here it's great it's
totally what I planned
oh oh I want to be know she gave him the
wall this is real Luke it is on PTR the
real is asking it's happening right now
in front of your public test region
we're on the we're on the new map
chateau de large yellow you are don't
look pick hard sorry it's all good in
advance
you're like Farah will dominate this
outside yeah yeah it's you don't want to
be outside at all unless you I wonder if
justice is Justin Calvert if I was
online I would be able to Oh kill
stealer robbed I was robbed
hot robbery in action do you know what
the call-out is and the police talk for
that oh no I don't well whatever we got
I don't know I'm just oh just trying to
get information for me yeah you know oh
this guy just yeah we're about to this
is about to be over he gets that last
kill yep justice reigns from above oh
there's that macri's we get out of this
outside area exam that Faris still there
yeah tough game tough game it's just
moving around trying to find the health
to heal up the rest of the way that's
good enough
no both flying away
he's a Nagi with of course he wins
because it's got so many perfect
wonderful that is one of the better it
really is I like that one in the the
shop putting one yeah it's a funny
character it was me it was me that was
also him goodness well that's a good
time yeah thanks Ben
yeah so the new deathmatch modes
free-for-all as well as team deathmatch
they're both currently available on PC
only on the public test region if you
own the game you can go into your region
section on the Blizzard app and select
public test region if you haven't
already installed it's about 10 gigs and
then you can download an update for this
has a new map obviously ICU I'll I
didn't I see you but thank you to
everyone that tuned in thanks to Ben
obviously for playing make sure you guys
subscribe and follow us on the twitch
and the YouTube thanks everyone on
GameSpot as well so you guys got get
informed when we go live we go live
every day at 11:00 and we will be doing
so tomorrow as well with Jo and gently
but otherwise thanks everybody for
tuning in and see you later good bye
[Music]